there and if Liam wins the match today
in the rapid portion to gain three
points he will be on 10 points only two
points behind Magnus with uh
how many matches to play two matches to
play after today hey if they go to uh
blade start breaks if they are tied in
the rapid portion then the winner and
tie breaks gets two points to lose your
one point here we go this is game one
with Magnus and Liam this is game one
and it's a very classical opening from
Magnus none of the free freewheeling
freestyling type of uh kind of
experimental play that we've seen from
him throughout the tour this season it's
the Spanish opening and it's not just
the Spanish it's the open Spanish that
is indicated by this last move Black's
Knight capturing a pawn in the center
and Magnus pauses he will have
considered this this is quite a trendy
variation nowadays and Liam has played
this before as far as I know but uh yeah
Magnus how well has he done his homework
the lines here the variations tend to be
very forcing definitely I can remember
Liam playing this when he was in a
must-win situation in the Oslo Esports
and did he win no it was a draw yeah
that was in the final day yeah in the
final round when Liam if he had won that
game would have won the whole tournament
uh against Jordan vanfur East that game
it's true so this is what six months ago
now maybe even more but Liam has played
this Magnus looking out the window
apparently and uh he's just trying to
recall what he wanted to do Magnus
probably has two or three different
ideas against this opening but which one
will be the most surprisingly M that's
the question he's asking himself so when
Magnus is looking that way that is
recalling and the other way is uh
calculating normally if a player looks
to the left that is regarded as
memorizing if you look to the right
that's uh kind of that's a new area that
side of the brain tends to be kind of
coming up with stuff creative side
that's so cool at least that's what I've
heard and talking of being creative this
is not the main line white nearly never
goes for this at the top level nowadays
because if you look at what's happened
yes white has regained the pawn that was
sacrificed but suddenly black has the
bishop pair and uh once Black's Knight
moves away and blocks this Central File
luck is Rock Solid I'm so surprised at
this Choice it feels like Magnus maybe
not expecting this opening just decided
to play it safe yeah I can I can see
that it's not the most popular line but
it has been played before
um I've seen that Alexander grishek did
draw with the white pieces against
Gregory apparent in 2020 but um this
position until the last move kind of
looks like another opening like the
Berlin variation somehow yeah exactly
and compared to those lines of the
Berlin not the end game of the Berlin
that we talk about sometimes but those
other lines there black doesn't have the
bishop pair and here yes there's a small
um there's a small issue long term with
Black's Pawn structure there's Double C
pawns but that is not a factor at the
moment and white has to compensate for
the fact that black has those two
Bishops by playing dynamically actively
and speeding things up that's what
Magnus is doing with this Pawn push I
can pretty much guarantee that Liam has
not studied this recently at least
anytime I've looked at the openings at
the open Spanish I've gone in a
different direction I've never ever
considered this for white just because
it looks relatively unambitious yeah and
I I can tell you black has actually a
whole range of options in this
particular position the most popular
move is actually to kick back the White
Knight pick up the F pawn move it one
square forward
another line which actually doesn't
score well with black is actually to put
the bishop on the F6 Square
alternatively the bishop can relocate
itself to D6
but the most uh the best variation
according to the numbers is actually to
attack the Knight yeah with the porn
yeah I think all of these three moves
right there to do with kicking this
Knight back or at least trying to
exchange it off but kicking the Knight
back it does make a lot of sense you've
got to be 100 sure about these types of
moves because you do create weaknesses
White Knight doesn't have too many safe
Retreats it will step back most likely
to this square and now suddenly the
Black Knight in the middle of the board
is a bit loose it might get kicked by a
pawn it's uh it's still a while before
black can feel fully safe and okay we do
see this position on the board now and
Liam decides to move his Rook across
that whole idea is to drop his Bishop
back perhaps on the next move or move it
out the way and then the black Rook will
nicely defend its own Knight yeah solid
start to this one again I'm not too
impressed I've got to say for magnus's
opening I wanted to see something more
uncompromising just something which will
challenge black a bit more but uh still
a lot of life left Magnus now he'll
bring his Knight out he'll move his
Queen up somewhere and swing his Rook us
and from there white is still very
active with the remaining pieces on the
board
and we do see the retreat getting ready
to bring the black Bishop out hmm
all right we have mentioned it is a very
big day today for Magnus Carlsen his
very own new official app is launching
today the Magnus chess Academy today
only available available for iOS and an
Apple Store will be available for
Android as well very shortly but head to
play magnus.com if you want to learn
more or to the Apple Store and download
this very cool app because we will have
a challenge for the viewers today yeah
we do we're asking everyone to download
the app and play the game Ace in the
sleeve and you'll start off at level one
and this of course you can download this
app for free at Play magnus.com but we
want to know how you did on this
particular Challenge and we do have some
surprises in store but first of all
let's see how you get on before those
surprises yeah those little secrets get
revealed and remember tweet us using the
hashtag chess Champs you know take a
screen grab of yourself playing the the
the challenge yeah show us your scores
plus what you think did you find it easy
is it hard we want to know
I tried it so level one was quite easy I
did that uh I did good at the level one
I was very happy with myself but there
are in total 12 levels so we want to
know how many levels can you do what
when do you start really struggling test
it it's it's a super fun way to learn
chess I really loved it this is a this
is definitely an app that you can get
hooked on I bet you as well David
if I had a yeah if I had iOS I would
download it and I get hooked I did
actually have the opportunity a few days
ago before it was released to try out
level 12 and yeah it's testing but I
agree with you Kai it's addictive it's
like the gamer in me wants to just sit
there and solve those puzzles non-stop
break my record and I'll be fascinated
to see if the viewers can actually get
to level 12 or how many levels they can
get through yeah and it does help the
pattern recognition for sure absolutely
and the Ace in the sleeve game that we
are challenging you guys to test is a
game where you're gonna put black in
Checkmate by placing out chess pieces
basically chess pieces on cards so
you're going to place cards to Checkmate
black
very fun game it is love we had a little
bit of a preview of The Players I can't
wait to share with you guys because of
course the players how some of the top
players have done and I can't wait to
see how you guys at home do and Magnus
bopping away look at him he's happy it's
a good time for him wherever he is in
the world listening listening to music
yeah in chess land yeah he's much more
awake this time than that that previous
match we saw against Liam I'm not sure
what he was singing maybe we can get
some info into his playlist a bit later
on Magnus but uh yeah he's looking happy
and usually for Magnus but all for all
chess players if you're happy if you're
relaxed you play well and that's why
he's been doing so great so far this
tournament meanwhile Liam just pushing a
point I'm expecting Magnus to bring his
Rook his remaining rook in the corner
over into the center at some point where
it's middle
uh pawns could step forward
yes still a lot of life left
I think both sides have reason to be
happy Magnus because he's got out of the
opening without walking into some deep
preparation
and Liam because he's still solid that's
black yeah and uh how many moves in we
had 14 moves in and uh do you think this
thing is running through Liam's mind
because often when I'm playing someone
very very strong my big goal
a short-term goal I should say is to
survive until move 20. you don't want to
get like a lost position or a much worse
position you want to have somewhere a
position where you have some chances and
I consider that like a success and then
the next goal is move 30 40 with 100 and
200.
200 yeah no David
fast move 60 and I'm satisfied but
you're right I mean survival there's
different types of styles in chess a lot
of players they try to win out of the
opening Liam is one of them he's very
principled he's maybe one of the most
professional players I've ever seen out
in the Chess World he studies opening so
deeply he has his ideas he sticks to
them he never backs down he'll happily
repeat those openings just to show he
knows more understands more but then
there's another style of player like
Magnus who he knows his stuff he has his
favorite openings but he's also happy to
Freestyle and normally those kind of
innovative players who want to make
things up as early as possible who want
to get into new territory they just want
to survive and the older I get the more
I'm heading into that camp nowadays when
I sit down at the board I'm like strong
player weak player no matter what I'm
just like okay as long as I survive the
first 10 20 moves I'm happy I can
outmaneuver them later
and uh we're at move 15 both sides have
survived neither side's really in their
homework anymore so this is really just
against Carson no opening prep no more
Theory no help from engines no pattern
recognition necessarily anymore it's
just brain versus brain I like that kind
of scenario but there is some there is
one game that they're following they're
following Stephen Le Pen oh now they're
not
Yep this is totally new no one's ever
played this before okay those two
players here Ivanka you were going to
mention yeah and then they disappeared
from my thing but there were two amateur
players
about the 1900s okay I'm pretty sure
Magnus and Liam they wouldn't have seen
that game before
they're just on their own right now okay
Liam's Bishop comes out very sensible
blocking a diagonal
eyeing up the White Queen Perhaps it is
a bit provocative this last bishop move
he's inviting Magnus to step forward
with White's d-pawn which d-pawn can hit
this like light squared Bishop
but I'm expecting Magnus maybe to build
up for that first it feels like that
rook in the corner really just wants to
get into the game Magnus is so good of
inviting every piece to those parties
and uh yeah bring the Rook across
why not centralize coordinate
it's a it's a good lesson in life
prepare and uh there you go he maximizes
his pieces and gets ready to push the
Deep Pawn one square forward
and uh black
if I were black I would pops take some
time out just to retreat my Bishop so
that when the d-pawn does move forward
it's not attacking a piece yeah this is
really instructive you anchor I
completely agree wholeheartedly here
there is a big threat if you look at
White's pieces they're all pretty much
on their optimal squares right now
they're all perfectly placed they can't
really be improved so it's clear Magnus
is about to break forward and Liam plays
exactly the move you wanted white only
idea to break forward is to push in the
center with D5 hitting the bishop so why
not step back and when this does happen
I'm pretty sure it's going to happen now
uh what else for Magnus simply but when
it does happen at least now black has
options your Bishop is no longer hit so
yes you can take and open things up but
if you want to play a karma karma
position then you can just block which
you wouldn't have been able to do if
your Bishop was vulnerable on this E6
Square so that's what we call
prophylaxis in chess just you see your
opponent's threat you guard against it
before it even arrives on the board and
suddenly I'm not sure whether Magnus
would be too happy with this position
some me what's his Queen doing out here
on a limb not really doing too much and
yeah these this Rook especially it looks
great but it is just staring down at its
own Pawn which can no longer advance
so I really really love that last move
by Lim I think really instructive a lot
of people would have been carried away
maybe move the queen maybe move the Rook
I don't know move the Knight but nope
just step back and ask the question what
are you actually going to do now you
have no more direct threats
and yeah great move by Liam this is what
makes him so classy he's great at
Dynamic play but he can also take time
out uh with these little sophisticated
Maneuvers yeah and what I also really
like about that Bishop Retreat is that
the bishop can actually go to the other
direction can actually plant itself at
the right time on H5 and again Ask white
how are you going to defend your night
not an easy question to answer yep could
be an annoying pin later on in the game
and meanwhile Black's next two moves if
white does nothing a very
straightforward Black's just going to
move his Queen then shift kind of
Shuffle his Rook across one uh into the
center but what's white doing I don't
see any idea for white at all here other
than pushing in the middle
yeah suddenly yes the evaluation Bar
says 0.1
but White's plans are quite mysterious
it's very simple for black to play uh so
you're
you're better for Liam basically I'm
also biased Kaya you know me and my two
Bishops that's true these two pieces
could become fantastic later in the game
if they're allowed to break out
the bind and minus he's uh thinking now
for over two minutes on his next move
we're gonna go to San Francisco where
Tonya is with a player that actually
participated previously on the season of
the tour
it's a fun day here at the venue we've
got so many chess enthusiasts players
here with us discussing everything
that's going on in the tour with the
players forms how much in shape Magnus
is just the way he's played so far and
today we've got a very special guest
joining us it is the U.S junior chess
champion he did make his debut at the
Champions Chester this year earlier at
the Julius bear generation cup impressed
us all with this phenomenal performance
Christopher you Christopher welcome
thank you so much
um it was I was very
fun to play um at the US Championship
despite it not ending that well I still
had many good games and it was really
fun interesting to face the top players
and it was definitely a new level I
hadn't really experienced before that
event because before that event I had
mostly only played like other people
around my wedding like um 2500 or 2600
so it was actually a lot more fun to
play these top players to be honest
and Christopher we were so impressed
with you qualifying to The Knockout
stages of your first event what did that
mean for you
yeah I was elated I was like I was
jumping up and down when it happened
especially since I had lost the first
two games of the tournament and I really
wasn't feeling so great but after losing
the first two games I really my form
really picked up and somehow I managed
to come back and make it to the
knockouts
it was really it was very cool to watch
that I have to ask you what is it like
to actually have the players here in
your city play the tour finals
it's really nice but um I do with I do
wish that I could play obviously
but I can I can still enjoy watching and
just and I cannot really enjoy being
here too with such a nice view
I completely agree about the view and I
have to ask you that at the U.S
Championship you made big headlines when
you beat Wesley as well but there were
so many stories especially that incident
with Savion breaking off the king
against the Hans that was the most
bizarre thing I've ever seen in my life
what happened there you've got to tell
us
I don't really know what happened
because Han said something to me but Sam
Savion said some that he said something
totally different than what Han said he
said to me but all I know is that they
had they had something going on it
wasn't it wasn't all chill among them
and they're definitely not unfriendly
terms after that
what about you I remember there were
these interviews also after your own
game because uh Hans did grow up around
here you played a lot as kids how's your
relationship with Hansen are you guys
good friends
yeah I I know him very well but I I
wouldn't personally say we're super good
friends but
he can be very entertaining at times
I couldn't agree more with you enough to
ask you in this event the tour final we
do have Wesley who's qualified he is uh
the American player for the finals are
you rooting for him
yeah yeah yeah
I'm not I don't have it I definitely
don't have anything against him so I
wouldn't say I'm particularly ready for
him but
I would like to see him do well yeah and
Christopher what do you make of magnus's
form in this event because that's been
impressive amazing just like
Magnus Carls Magnus Carlson on good form
is just really scarily good
it's super hard to play against him as
is but when he's in shape it sits really
tough yeah
oh I don't feel as bad
I'm like zero six against him online
which is a bit rough and I do still
really want to beat him
but he's declining my challenges when
when I challenge him so I hope that he
can watch this and accept one of my
challenges online instead of declining
all of my challenges because I do really
want to play him
well we loved having you on the tour do
you enjoy these online formats with the
rapid and Blitz and the Champions
Chester
yeah I really I really enjoy these
formats and I would personally say that
I I really like playing in these formats
myself
um so I hope that this keeps happening
and there's and that this tour goes on
many years in the future
well as do we and we've got chess action
on so we're gonna head back to the
studio we'll report back soon from San
Francisco
fantastic thank you Tanya and
Christopher this is from uh before the
game started today Christopher you was
uh lucky he got to test out Magnus
Carlson's chair inside the shack 15
Arena The Grandmaster himself of course
but uh for a young player like him
Magnus will be big Idol right yeah of
course Magnus is a big inspiration to
many young players and actually to
several chess players over the world and
there we see a photo of the actual scene
that he was talking about how to enhance
Neiman and Sam Sevin they did that talk
about that very strange moment Tanya
call it the strangest moment she's seen
in chess in her life when some Savion
broke off the crown of the king in the
middle of the game against Hans Neiman
that was so bizarre yeah it was actually
Hans Neiman's move and then Sam as white
just picked up the opponent's king while
the Clock Was ticking just snapped off
the cross on top of the King and just
started fiddling with it as if nothing
had happened and then we see Hans just
his surprise and it's really fascinating
Christopher giving some insight there
which I don't think anyone knew around
the world this is like breaking news
yeah there was actually some personal
stuff between them because afterwards
the players they were like oh no no no
it's just a misunderstanding just
but apparently some some thing going on
behind the scenes now ah
strange strange moment that we all know
there has been moments between Magnus
Carlsen himself and Hans Newman this
season both in St Louis singfield cup
and on the tour
the hair magnets is fighting to win
the tour finals he's already the winner
of the mouthwater Champions just tour
2022 will he finish off with winning the
prestigious tour finals before we headed
the the Tanya in San Francisco you kind
of liked it for Liam the position what
do you think now after a few moves um I
still think black is fine but suddenly
things have changed uh the center the
tension there has resolved itself and
now Liam is pushing on the queen side
and uh maybe we can jump in just to show
what has happened how that situation did
clarify so this is the current position
but we left it here a few moments ago so
we did say that white is going to break
forward in the center black blocked it
up here Magnus brought his Bishop to a
more active Square this is a clear
Target the base of Black's Pawn chain
and therefore Liam said okay I don't
want to tolerate this tension any longer
slightly surprising to me perhaps but he
immediately rushed to trade off Bishops
I still like the potential of the bishop
pair maybe he could have delayed this a
few more moves but after a rook trade
and now a bishop trade this is where I
was really surprised uh yes Liam has a
set of double pawns and he corrected his
Pawn structure by taking now but
suddenly there were weaknesses
especially this black porn watch out for
that one being a weakness a Target later
it's a clear backward Pawn Magnus now
just improved his Rook to an open file
and Liam immediately broke out
sacrificing upon temporarily we see an
exchange here Magnus capturing that
sacrifice pawn it is defended remember
this Knight by the White Queen and after
a pin the moves are coming thick and
fast but white defended and uh after a
Trader pieces look at White's Pawn
structure it is a bit ragged it is
ruined here double pawns isolated pawns
but how can black take advantage it's
not 100 clear this Black Knight
especially not really joining the action
anytime soon it takes three or four
moves to hop around and threaten those
pawns maybe Liam's idea is to come with
his Queen to one of these two squares
I guess the first target has to be the
advanced B Pawn
what do you think Ivanka does he have
enough compensation
um
it's a very difficult position actually
because I do I mean I have to say Liam's
last move was actually my first move of
choice but I was wondering what's going
to happen once Magnus just starts
launching forward his works and uh since
he just cannot preserve the pawn on B5
he might as well maximize his pieces but
here I was just trying to assess this
and I was thinking
this is very complicated position
because yes some Queens might get traded
off but the Rooks are very active and
black has terrible Pawn structure I mean
the pawn on D6 is so weird and White's
night is primed and ready to perhaps
jump over to some important squares yeah
um even if the Queens come off maybe
white has some small chances here in an
end game due to the weakness of this
Pawn uh he might even allow this one to
drop just to get forward with his Knight
towards Black's d-pawn and this one
feels like it might fizzle towards a
draw if the Queens do come off so the
big question for Magnus if we go back to
the current position is can he prevent
this somehow I don't see a way either
I've got to admit ideally you want to
bring your Rook forward and hear kind of
keep the Queens on somehow zigzag the
queen across to the king side to attack
but this does take a few moves and
meanwhile black will start gobbling up
some even more pawns uh the one good
thing about Black's night it's not on a
great Square actively but defensively
it's very decent it covers some key
squares nice on f8 no mate and it can
always come out and block any threats
yeah maybe Liam is just about holding it
does look a bit scary uh the king and
queen we've seen this scenario so many
times of uh the queen kind of divorced
from the King just so far away on the
other side of the board and then there's
a direct attack against the king she
can't defend but right now Magnus he
doesn't have too much ammunition left he
doesn't have too many pieces to create
those threats
so maybe just maybe Liam has calculated
his way to safety
important game important match this one
Liam he was able to
destroy everything for young Christoph
Duda yesterday when he beat him in that
match Judah wasn't a shared lead with
Magnus heading into day four yesterday
but Liam winning that match means Duda
is now three points behind Magnus on the
standings and Ruda is today facing
pragnananda Prague was for big parts of
the season number two overall on the
tour standings but do not playing in the
final and winning the previous
tournament in chess rapid he has now
taken that second place and also winning
a bunch of matches in the tour finals is
still in second place but this has been
the two best players behind Magnus
Carlsen this season so this is a match
we are definitely keeping a close eye on
as well and I think I did yeah the bar
very much over to do that side in game
one yeah yeah that game opened as a
Catalan opening and it does look like
Duda so far is in charge wow he's out
prepared pregnant these two have history
I remember the first time they played in
the Oslo Esports I mean dude it was just
convincing he beat pragananda in three
games but when it came came to the
rematch in the FTX a crypto cup well
guess what happened I mean pragnanda was
actually winning the match and it was do
you know in the in the kick you see that
big moment when I was like oh no that
was Duda because Prague was totally
winning when he checkmated himself yeah
they allowed the dude as such a horrible
moment and that was against Duda yeah
and that was the last time these two
played a match together so that will be
a nightmare that Prague remembers last
time he played a match against Duda that
could well be the biggest blunder we've
ever seen from a GM not just on the tour
but in general plundering into meeting
one it happens once in a lifetime If
You're a Grand Master especially from
such a winning position
to kind of see the game turn completely
360 in one move it's uh yeah it's
heartbreaking so Prague we know he's
good at recovering he had a difficult
start to this tournament he's already
bounced back yesterday was
um oh sorry the day before was a good uh
performance from him but
yeah it's going to be an uphill struggle
in that game as we see against Duda
right now he is on seven points after
the first four matches Prague in a
shared place with Anish
sorry Four Points
exam Four Points yep that's correct I'm
watching Liam last score
pregnant he's on four points and shared
plays with Anish uh Geary uh so
is there even a chance for him to win
the tournament three six nine oh well
Magnus will have to lose everything so
he's not gonna win the Tour finals prag
but he can still finish in style
three matches left to play yeah I think
it was just the top four on the top half
of the table who still have some chances
for Wesley it's not going to be easy he
relies on Magnus losing a couple of
matches yeah everyone at this point
relies on Magnus slipping up
but I don't think it's going to slip up
in this game it does look like
despite the simplified material it's
only white really who can play for
Advantage it feels like black is the one
who has to be quite accurate there is a
trap on the board as well and uh I don't
think Liam will fall into it but it just
to show this Elementary trap don't get
greedy before you can capture anything
in your opponent's camp this you should
always double check to make sure they
haven't set up a nasty surprise for you
Queen takes pawn it looks like the pawn
was undefended but look at the queen
look at The Rook they're lined up on the
same file and they can be skewered now
by whites Rook stepping across and the
white Rook is protected so here black
would lose material if you move the
queen out the way the black rip drops
and if black takes the white Rook here
it's actually level material but for
sure the queen is superior to the black
Rooker Knight Black's rook and Knight
are just not combined they're not
coordinated if they were maybe they
could hold a White Queen we'll just jump
in grab some pawns and win the game so
uh yeah right now I'm not expecting Liam
to blunder the fact that he post and
he's been thinking two and a half
minutes now means he for sure is not
going to capture this pawn and the big
question for him then is what else can
you do you don't really want to move
your knight if you move your knight then
the White Queen can jump in with a nasty
check this would be incredibly dangerous
uh if you can't move the Black Knights
why do you really want to push the Rook
too it looks pretty good right now so
how do you even improve your position
maybe you have to improve the black
queen but again where do you put her
lots of questions here fully and
meanwhile Magnus has a clear idea that's
to jump in with his Knight and Target
this big weakness on D6 we caught it
earlier on when he took uh with a Pawn
on this Square we said this is going to
be the target for Magnus and he's going
after it
instructive play from Magnus I agree
with you David it's the black queen that
needs to be moving and she needs to get
out of the way of her work yeah I mean
there's a few squares uh you can I mean
drop back for example if you want to be
really solid you could maybe drop back
here just to keep an eye on white
Central Pawn
and uh yeah you could make an argument
for stepping forward to one of these two
squares just to stay active
but lots and lots of choice and it's not
clear which one is best and Liam does
have to move he's down at four minutes
now one minute behind Magnus on the
clock but that could be a significant
factor because the critical moments are
still ahead in this game Magnus will ask
some difficult questions and wow he does
go for this we said this was a blunder
but he's relying on sacrificing his
Queen Liam
surely he didn't miss this move the Rook
coming across he has to give up his
Queen we said that this was losing but
does he really believe that he can build
a fortress here how can you hold this
position when you have such a weak Pawn
when your rook and Knight is so
disconnected
maybe he's evaluated this better than us
but uh it would be a shock now to me if
he can hold the draw
it's only two results now it's either
white winning or a draw black has to
somehow curl up into a ball he has to
somehow Retreat his Rook maybe to defend
and cross his fingers and hope wow to me
this is the Magnus effect because in the
the position until he played this queen
sacrifice I mean everything was fine he
he didn't have any problems but I mean I
have to say I do like Liam's last movie
using all his pieces but still this
isn't necessary it's only Magnus who's
going to be able to win this before you
know anything could happen yeah I mean
yeah you're definitely just fighting for
the draw now if you're Liam I'm so
shocked I'm almost speechless I've got
to admit I think his idea is for example
if the White Queen comes to Target this
Pawn Black's Rook is just in time to
slide back and it's still hard to
pinpoint weaknesses in the black camp
that you can Target white is just
playing with the queen but Magnus is
trying to get in from this angle uh the
black Rook drops back and look how
passive Black's pieces are now Black's
Rook is stuck however it's defended by
the Black Knight and these three pieces
are basically going to sit on these
three squares for the rest of the game
and he's gonna hope that white can't
break through it's so funny Magnus
himself has held a fortress this
tournament and we've seen a couple of
other fortresses but now Liam he's
trying to say to Magnus yes they do
exist yes you can't break through and
the evaluation bar seems to agree that
black is holding is going to be a tough
slog now to defend this one yeah yeah I
agree with you there David and also I'm
just thinking about the psychological
effect because it goes to show that Liam
is very happy with the draw he wasn't
interested in fighting a game with three
results possible instead he was just
like okay I respect your skill your
Genius and I'm just simply gonna hold
the position tightly I would be feeling
very positive about the match if I were
Magnus but what is the most likely
result right now if you guys just walked
in and saw this board is it a win for
minus or is draw still the most likely
somewhere in between I would say that
maybe this is a draw 60 of the time and
Magnus wins 40 of the time or or maybe
it's a draw 70 30 roughly around there
so I was going to say that black has to
just sit still and wait but now Liam
he's happy to actually try and go active
he's trying to get his knight uh forward
he's trying to capture this Pawn he is
however giving up his Pawn in the center
but I think he's okay with that right
now I was going to say surely white can
just grab this Pawn but after the Black
Knight captures suddenly white has
created a passport yes but it's still
going to take a while to advance for
example black can just retreaters night
and even if you give up another point
maybe this is the Fortress that Liam is
relying upon the Black Knight on a nice
Outpost here you can never kick it away
with a white Pawn anymore
and uh he will just slide his Rook
across and say okay you're not advancing
still looks a bit shaky to me as black
but he does have a point it's going to
be difficult to dislodge that Black
Knight
what do you think Ivanka
is he gonna hold this one Liam and we
might be headed in this direction
actually Magnus is going for this Pawn
I mean it's very clever Balian but I do
feel it's it
died and I don't think it bodes well for
the match situation I just
yeah normally the players who beat
Magnus they're playing for the win
they're aggressive uh they're yeah they
keep all three results open you very
rarely beat Magnus in a match as you
mentioned uh Ivanka in this type of
format by just playing for a draw maybe
he'll play for a draw with black and try
and go for it as widely and maybe that's
the strategy but not too positive stuff
from the Vietnamese player now I'm
expecting him either to use the square
or this Square
the goal is to get the Knight onto E5
that's the square you want to keep the
Black Knight on
you just have to Simply stop white porn
white does have a passport and those are
killers when you have a queen to to kind
of Shepherd that pawn forward but
okay I think he can defend he's still
within the Realms of a fortress
okay
Liam is uh fighting for a draw in this
game Magnus Crossing is this like a
typical Magnus game where he can sort of
grind and no risk yeah he pushes a pawn
forward this is so again it just feels
like oh look at that yeah you're
weakening your position if you want to
hold a fortress in chess you kind of
have to just curl up into a ball sit
there just defend your squares be
patient just wait and hope your opponent
can't break through you can't lash out
and push pawns like this now the black F
Pawn the pawn in front of the black king
that one is a target long term it's a
bit softer it's a bit more vulnerable
than it was earlier yes you've got your
knight on a good square but you're
defending actively when you can't defend
actively if your material down like this
white can just move the queen out of the
way now and stop pushing the spawn
forward
I don't like it the valuation bar agrees
sometimes human instinct is enough to
tell you that this move is too risky
you can also show some inconsistencies
actually because uh right at the
beginning you know when he went into
this ending it seemed to me that he was
going to curl up in a ball then he went
active with a knight and said hey you
can take my big asset the D6 Pawn that
held the position together but still you
know and now he's playing it feels like
he's trying to keep his pieces active
but
that's not part of the plan you know
even a bad pla even a bad plan is better
than no plan you know and the plan was
to Simply
hold
and uh he's just impatience he's
changing his mind on every single move
right he gives up a queen gave me for
the Fortress then he's like no I'm gonna
try and win with my active Knight and
then he should just Retreat go passive
again but he's like no I'm gonna go
active again it's like uh identity
crisis
I think it's not in his nature as well
I've I've grown up alongside Liam he's
just one year younger than Magnus myself
and others we played him in all these
age groups and he was always very active
he I very rarely ever saw him just sit
still and hold passively it's just not
in his nature so unfortunately the
position demanded that he kind of curl
up into that ball
but now a cave Magnus pushing forward
already the position for black is
starting to creak Magnus could have
moved his Queen I was a bit surprised
there that would have been the most
logical white has to win this game if
you want to win it as white by pushing
your past deep Pawn forward but first
he's just trying to soften black up even
more on the king side with these pawns
on the right flank so he's trying to
undermine the pawn protecting the Black
Knight so black cannot capture this
white porn that's just moved because the
White Queen will come swoop back and
take the Black Knight but Liam does have
one move now
how can he take advantage of that and
he's going active again it's his style
he's staying true to himself but is that
what the position requires is that the
spirit of the position he's going after
pawns but even the pawns near the white
king they don't matter it's all about
the white Central Pawn ah that is the
only way that white will win the game so
I would rather have eliminated that
white Central Pawn than go for the pawns
near
White's King yeah and looking at the bar
hates it doesn't like this strategy from
Liam and I agree you know the Deep porn
is very strong but also I I suspect that
Magnus is going to go about opening up
the black king and just the subjecting
him to some checks from his queen and
the queen is such a strong piece because
she can lose time the Knight and the
bishop were less flexible it's not in a
bishop Knight and the Rook
they can't lose as much time as the
queen
all right so Magnus he is uh definitely
trying to Checkmate the black king and
that's exactly what we are asking you
guys to do in our challenge for you
today Magnus Carlsen is today launching
his very new official app the Magnus
chess Academy and within that app
there's a bunch of games we are
challenging you in the game called the
ace up the sleeve where the aim is to
Checkmate the black king using a bunch
of cards so test the game download it
download the app first of all the Magnus
chess academy test the game called
um Ace up the sleeve and let us know how
you do how many levels can you do what
level do you start struggling at
it's a fun game I want to know their
scores
I mean every chess player always asks
that you know you say I was playing a
tournament oh what was the score so I'm
going to ask the same to you guys at
home and tweets us your score tweet us
at what level you're at yeah and uh
whether you're enjoying the game
I can't wait to hear their feedback and
I bet you when they see how the players
get on yeah oh no one will be able to
resist oh they're going to be motivated
to beat Magnus Carlson score we're going
to reveal after this game how Magnus did
in that game and just to clarify the app
is called Magnus chess Academy and the
game within the app that we want you
guys to try is called Ace of the sleeve
but the app you need to download only
available in iOS Apple store today will
be available Android also coming shortly
but the app is called minus chess
Academy and I think Magnus has been
inspired he's been trying out this app
he's been learning from it and he's
going for checkmate with this Pawn push
the White H Pawn stepping forward he's
going for the black king and now Black's
King is trying to run away desperately
he's trying to find a shelter we have to
jump in we have to show what's happening
because it's a lot of drama a lot of
hidden tactics actually on the board and
uh last move Magnus pushed this Pawn
forward it looks like this Pawn is up
for grabs you can capture it with the
Black Knight you can create an escape
Square for the black king however now
blacks Knight is so far offside it's on
the edge of the board it can no longer
run back in time to stop white spawn
this would be a check for example and uh
if the black king moves the white Pawn
steps forward and just to show just to
illustrate the danger if Black's Rook
blocks then white Pawn can step forward
giving up the White Queen and making a
new Queen next move because Black's
Knight is so bad meanwhile uh Liam
didn't go for this he decided okay the
black king is in some Danger from some
tracks he wants to run in front of the
pawn he's going to try and use this
point of shelter but Magna says okay you
can do that I don't care I'm just going
to take a pawn and uh even after black
grabs his former track he just
back and uh now it's all about the Deep
Pawn
I think if black can give up his night
for this Pawn there might be some
chances to hold the game but Magnus will
try and force the win of the black Rook
for this white one yeah and unfortunate
fortunately for Liam it's not just the
d-pawn that's running through the black
king is also incredibly vulnerable so if
the Rook say for instance tries to get
behind the past pawns after all that's a
good defensive technique then the queen
will come into the E7 square and that's
bad news for black because the king is
going to get hunted down yeah you have
to start running forward now and this
will end in disaster I mean white can
start grabbing some pawns already I'm
not sure whether white wants to take
immediately or White can just step
forward and now there's no path black
for the Black Knight to come and stop
this Pawn this Pawn is simply promoting
it will cost black as rook and white
will win a queen of verses Knight is
very simple very simple Victory so Liam
now he's only got 20 seconds left and
this is the current position he faces
two threats the biggest one is this
check so he does prevent it he brings
this Rook across but how is he going to
stop the second threat White's Pawn can
just move you can start pushing already
this looks terminal
yeah it's good to go and there it is
past pawns must be pushed and the Knight
does jump back to attack the queen and
there you go
check on the board it looks like a
deadly check when the king moves when it
starts to run White's Queen has a bunch
of squares to choose from but it could
for example use this Square it pins the
Black Knight along this line and it's
grabbing this Pawn next move you just
step forward and it's going to be game
over
looks like this Pawn is going to cost
black the game
and it's all because he went too active
look at how poorly coordinated blacks
pieces are now earlier they all
protected each other suddenly the the
Knight The Rook these are pinned the
black king off on the other side in
order to hold a fortress in order to
defend an endgame against a queen you
need to defend all your pieces they need
to protect each other
you have three pieces against one after
all use them together don't just put
them randomly on the side of the board
even if you're grabbing some pawns look
at Black's King he is getting active he
is grabbing pawns but uh after this move
you're running through for example if
the black king moves again white will
make a new Queen and after the Black
Knight captures it's not the Knight you
take but it's the rook and you can no
longer save the black Rook
yeah here it's just a cleaning up
process you just slowly go and win all
these three pawns and then eventually
white activates his King and goes for
checkmate
wow Magnus Carlsen on
fear probably winning this game that
will be his eighth win in a row and
that's a record seven was a record eight
is a record on the mouthwater Champions
chess tour
yeah yeah and uh there's some there
seems to be something very lucky about
Magnus you know he seems to be getting a
lot of sometimes shaky positions
sometimes you know as we saw earlier it
was dead drone positions but the
opponents are all going wrong and so
someone seems to be smiling on him and
uh there we see the king step forward
the black king is also following suits
and are we going to see a move like
queening or we can see something flashy
yeah so I do like what Liam's done he
somehow tricked Magnus into into the
White Queen no longer pinning the black
knight uh there's a few ways you could
play this I would be tempted to bring
the White Queen back to start kicking
the black Rook just to ask it whether it
has any safe squares
if you want to play this safe I guess
you can make a new Queen uh as you
mentioned Ivanka you can promote that
will cost black as Knight but then we'll
see an endgame of Queen vs rook and two
pawns it is winning for white uh Black's
pawns are too far forward there's no
Fortress there but uh there's no rush I
guess you can make a new Queen anytime
you want you could win that black knight
anytime you want so Magnus first he'll
test Liam a bit and uh he's forcing Liam
to give a couple of checks
oh suddenly you know blacks pieces are
at least active they are at least
coordinated again the black king and
Rook protecting each other
but uh is that a knockout blow it should
still be winning for white
but at least black is now threatening to
give some nasty checks Black's Rook uh
and King have caged their the
counterpart the white king and that's
why Magnus gives a check but the king is
going to step to the side opposite the
white king and then Checkmate is
threatened yeah suddenly it's no longer
one-way traffic
should still be winning for white but
Liam is defending really well
and Magnus he still has to be very
accurate here I think he should have
kept it simple I think you were right
Ivanka just make a new Queen win that
black knight and then focus on hoovering
up focus on winning those black pawns
okay Liam retreats
and uh how will he finish this game off
now
it's not totally easy it's it's uh okay
maybe it's just a matter of taking pawns
Magnus feels he has that luxury why not
grab a pawn that black knight is fixed
where it is Black's Rook is fixed
defending it maybe Liam just has to wait
sit and await his fate I I was curious
about the situation if it was a rook and
queen sorry rook and porn versus queen
because there are some situations where
it is a draw
and we can show this for example uh if
we do see the same game we will be in
for a long grind here but if we see for
example White's uh I don't know how to
do this whites I think there's a very
strong move here I think you can give a
check but uh yeah let's say for example
black just waited uh White who's the
queen across and we see a position like
this one where Black's Knight can give
itself up for the pawn or the new Queen
uh so this end game you're wondering
about Ivanka when it's King rook and
porn and this one I'm pretty sure is
winning uh this would be a draw if the
pawn was back where it started and the
King was back as well because then you
can't break through buff from behind
here White's Queen will simply catch the
black king out in the open and
eventually you will win this pawn queen
vs Rook alone is a win so uh let's go
back to the game it does look like
Magnus doesn't even want to allow that
position to happen so this is the
current position and he's just trying to
make a new Queen and win that for the
black Rook rather than the Knight
and the question for Liam here is can he
go for the white king if you can't go
for the white king white makes a new
Queen game over seconds one second and
he gives a check this feels wrong now
the white king can start running out
into the open yeah I agree he needed to
step forward with his King For Better or
Worse and uh the king is running the
king is indeed running and this one I
think is just over uh the king doesn't
even need to run out of the open it can
just Shuffle across and attack the black
Rook this is a check now the white king
can just continue moving across if the
black Rook steps across this is a Check
Yes but white will just happily
sacrifice his Queen to make a new one
and we have a result Liam has resigned
wow Magnus takes the lead uh yet again
winning game number eight in a row